what inspired you to get your own tour
bus
because that's another thing though you
said like you know
people got to start thinking this way
man nah man like for real though i
really
i really caught a still like a a
blessing on it because i
uh it was this australian guy
and his his daughter was like a real fan
of my music so
uh i went to nashville one time like i
said i treated everybody with
yeah i treated i just treated everybody
with respect so he ain't hit me up he
was like man yeah you know i do i do
publishing and stuff like that i was
just like man yeah you know
uh let's talk about it so he picked me
up from the output
i went to his house and yeah big stupid
house you know what i'm saying so
end up coming to find out he ended up
being a
a singer from australia that had like
multiple number ones and stuff so he
owned a whole big
tour bus company and i was like man i
need i mean
i need a toy bus you feel me so uh
he was like uh he was like man i i get
you one like you know i'm saying there's
no problem
so uh yeah he gave me october
he gave you one yeah he gave me oh yeah
he gave him a tour but so
um that's funny well you know what what
he really did was
you might want to say he gave it to me
because i gave him twenty thousand for
it
but the toy was worth like two hundred
thousand you know saying i gave him
twenty thousand four so
[ __ ] uh and after that you don't say i
had broken my own like
managing me for a little while you know
saying and uh stuff like that so it was
like
you know it was kind of he was letting
me use it you know saying while i was
managing and stuff but
he had ended you know getting into like
some
multi-million dollar deals with some
stuff
and you know we still keep in touch with
he was just like you know
yeah ain't really so now you rent the
tour bus out to other artists
yeah yeah i'll rent it out to other
other people now like
it'd be artists families stuff like that
you know what i'm saying yeah
so yeah so oh nick on that
uh yeah for real though but i probably
would have [ __ ] like
got because i got like sprinkles and
stuff too so i probably would eventually
got my own i just like how
it is you know what i'm saying it saved
me because it got like a whole
king bedroom in the back you know what
i'm saying stuff like that so it's
saving for help to get rooms
if i want to go like out and just hit
city the city the city of the city and
make money you know
saying i could go do it you know it's
good i'm just on the bus